video game Easter eggs can be unexpected
they can be wholesome
they can be edgy don't you think we've
seen enough today we are looking at 25
secrets and hidden details that are a
little bit naughty and be warned the
further into this video we go the more
outrageous they become yes we'll see
about that but let's start small did you
know that the NPCs in Red Dead
Redemption 2
fart and but after eating especially the
ladies
over in Far Cry 5 you can find a town
completely inhabited by mannequins doing
everyday tasks but look around enough
and you'll spot these two obviously
they're only stretching right unlike
these cars in Destroy All Humans in a
secluded spot these vehicles start
rocking and the windows steam up then
hand prints appear wait are they
Footprints we're still another person
will come and watch the action with you
Duke Nukem Forever took 14 years to
release and when it did comedy had moved
on a little but everyone loves a toilet
gag
uh no what am I doing and this game lets
you pick up and throw human turds
if you think you've seen everything in
GTA 5 then I suggest you look at the
Gnomes usually they can be fishing or
just smiling but sometimes there's a
gnome that goes too far full-on mooning
his friend in a very suggestive position
in another GTA game Vice City be sure to
look at this building at night because
the lights outline something rather rude
at exactly 11 pm until midnight enjoy
the view and hey that founting exploding
doesn't help me keep this video family
friendly over in death stranding it's
possible to control the camera while Sam
is relaxing Amy's added crotch for too
long and he'll become a little uneasy
keep going and eventually he'll snap
another crotch you could search out is
found in Star Wars Jedi Survivor over in
Kobo a secret cave can be found hiding
this passage it takes minutes to get
through but once there you'll find an
art class going on Droids are painting a
mogu just like in the movie Titanic The
Life drawing class is a full frontal
like no other sometimes characters ain't
so willing to show their junk the most
iconic is probably Ashley in the
original Resident Evil 4. by trying to
get a sneak peek at her undergarments
this response will be triggered oh you
pervert this is seen in other video
games too like Lollipop Chainsaw which
gives a trophy for trying to get the
camera to view something you really
shouldn't yet the Neo games ain't
standing for your shenanigans try to get
a glimpse of two bees undergarment and
she'll push the camera away
whereas in near replicant if you stare
for too long at this revealing outfit
why is that lady in her underwear
prepare yourself for this reaction you
think you're hard she'll call you out
and boot the camera away The Witcher 3
lets geralt's romance a lot of ladies
but should you try this on both Tris and
yennefer a very unique cutscene is
unlocked we couldn't wait for you to
show geralt thinks it's going to be the
best night of his life but instead the
two ladies chain him up and then leave
he's all alone and very awkward right
now Chris yeah
this guy finds him the next day
well well over two Metal Gear Rising and
some Sinister players figured out that
Ryden can use his Katana on civilians
but you may not expect this to happen
ripping off people's clothes
relax Boris just some Custom Tailoring
in a scene in Metal Gear Solid 2 Ryden
is back and finds himself interrogated
in the buff I'm very thankful for that
drink's positioning should he stay here
long enough a guard will come over and
comment on ryden's manhood always shy at
that let's do one more for riding whilst
being a stealthy secret agent it's
possible to get paid on the thing is if
Ryden uses his Kodak right now to call
his Superior officers he'll get
interactions like this sneaking missions
are called wetworks for a reason after
all don't worry about it Jack it's okay
rose that is as long as you take a
shower the second you get back ryden's
been through quite a lot so let's not
talk about that time he slipped in Birds
writing is everything all right in Dead
Rising we play as photographer
extraordinaire Frank West who has a very
strange ailment if he takes slightly
provocative pictures
fantastic he'll suddenly get a nosebleed
that is not sauce at all all right the
medieval Warface model somehow found
time to hide a web link in the game and
a not so nice message for Easter egg
hunters in a Hut on the outskirts of the
tiger map a very hard to see font is
here give me a sec I'll fix that it
reads nosy little butt aren't you and
where does this link send us to here to
Terry Crews thankfully he's holding a
basketball and now my Google searches
are forever cursed thanks Terry now you
try Arthur Morgan in Red Dead Redemption
2 can wander around the open world
freely yet occasionally it's possible to
find a few scamps looking through a
window get yourself over there and
prepare for the show well I've been a
bad boy again Mama a bad bad boy yes you
have
more like
if you tell a stove I swear I'll kill
you speaking of weirdos did you know
it's possible to find this peeping Tom
in Dishonored who can't resist looking
through this Keyhole go on guess what's
on the other side did you did you guess
this good thing we were here to stop him
but why are we doing it now walking in
and introducing yourself does not make
this any better can't you see I'm about
to bathe
I can't believe this when I took this
job they told me I'd worked with good
men if you pay attention to the cut
scenes in death stranding you'll find
out that Sam's urine can be used as a
weapon against the tar-like BTS but
would anyone be brave enough to try it
well yes yes they were and yes it
certainly works if you run out of
bullets in death stranding simply get
your other weapon out
GTA 5 loves to be edgy and a well-known
ability our anti-heroes have is to aim
when not holding a weapon this will make
hand gestures listen nobody likes you
but did you know the insults each
character shouts out are totally
dependent on who they are talking to oh
great a stinky crazy person oh old
people are so depressive the strangest
Easter egg on this list is thanks to
Ratchet and Clank and this innocent
looking alien lady Welcome to The
hovercon Intergalactic hoverboard
competition for some reason the
developers decided to add a piece of
coding that made her chest expand every
time ratchet completed a spin jump in a
few moments she goes from this to this
here's a before and after because if
you're this far into the video you
definitely want to see things like this
the remake of Ratchet and Clank removed
this Easter egg but it's here forever in
the original and I bet she has back pain
now let's shock you with Revelations
about Princess Peach she's not as
innocent as she looks here in Paper
Mario we are tasked with finding so many
Collectibles and it's all going fine
until we enter this bedroom and locate
treasure number 69. not only is that
your mum's favorite number but this item
can only be found in the princess's
bedroom locked away rotating the item
doesn't do it any favors supposedly this
bedroom collectible is a call back to
Mario's RPG on the SNES where Mario
could freely walk around Peach's room
and hidden between the fireplace and the
chair is an object Mario can't recognize
immediately granny Toadstool will Dash
in and offer Mario a mushroom in return
for forgetting everything he just saw
and look here again with peach in your
party and she'll run in very agitated
and kicks Mario out I wonder what that
toy could have been who am I kidding it
must be her vibe scepter officially
revealed in super Princess Peach and
finally something you wouldn't want to
watch with your parents around in Metal
Gear Solid 5 we can build up a bond with
quiet a sniper with questionable dress
sense if the bond is high enough when we
return from a long time in the field and
we absolutely stink use stink
foreign
to join her in the shower as other
soldiers just watch it's really weird
and it's only possible to be seen once
ever I think that's enough naughtiness
for one day I'm Adam you're awesome I'll
see you next time don't you think of
soon enough